so thank you very much
so first I want to thank the organizers
of the Meetup max and Paul and also all
of you guys for coming over
hi dennis is the founder of our company
so today I'm going to talk about a
product that we're developing a textured
AI and first I want to say just give you
a little bit of the history of x3i so
accelerate a company that we've funded
about a year ago we've been doing
serious data science on that maybe six
to seven months already we've gone
through a serious a funding I have
collected about ten million dollars and
we are now a thirty man band out of
which 28 people are fully devoted to
developing the product so we're quite
deep into the game so used to give you a
little bit of the outline of this talk
so first I'm gonna give you you know
overview of the product then I'll give
you an overview of the actual
architecture of the product itself we're
we don't have a fully automated system
yet so I'll give you I'll try to explain
throughout the role of humans in our
architecture I'll talk about the
different areas of data science that we
have in this project so there's
different types of challenges and our
focus on how we handle time expressions
in text so it's an completely natural
language processing domain then I'll
show you the performance of our algos
say a few words our email classification
future work and then I'll just wrap it
up so let's start so what is aimy aimy
is the thing that we're trying to build
rx3i and it's essentially an automated
scheduling assistant nothing else
nothing more ambitious than that but
also nothing less than that so what does
that mean what does it mean to schedule
meetings let's say that for example you
wanted to schedule a meeting with him
and him and I was your personal
assistant say then I would need to know
something about your calendar so that
your calendar availability your
preferences and I would then compose a
message to these two other people saying
hey so-and-so wants to meet with you
guys propose sometimes propose a
location and then you guys would get
back to me back to the system and you
would say well that time doesn't work or
that time does work but that location
doesn't work etc and so then the system
needs to be able to understand your
response and start the sort of
negotiation with you right and
eventually we converge on a time and
place for the meeting and then that's it
the system needs to just send out and
meeting invite to everybody so that's
what's kind of involved in scheduling
meetings in a very very simplistic
description it's the case that most
meeting negotiations happen over email
at least in the domain in the business
domain or in the corporate domain so we
want to be both humble and focused and
see we don't want to expand the ability
of this automated assistant beyond the
domain of scheduling meetings and we
want to also stay in the domain of text
of meetings are scheduled over email
which because we're because it becomes a
singular focus project that limited
space actually helps us with the
performance quite a bit as I'll show
later in the talk I want to say a few
words about what Amy is not so amy is
not an apt it's not something that you
download into your phone it's not
something that you download into your
laptop so it's also not something that
you need to update whenever we have a
new release or whenever we create a new
feature
Amy server sort of invisible assistant
that you interact with through email and
over time you just learned
your preferences it learns what your
calendar is like and it learns how to
interact with the people that you meet
with so in that sense it's also a novel
product in the sense that it has a novel
way of onboarding the way that you
onboard Amy is simply next time you want
to schedule a meeting yes CeCe Amy so
amy has an email address you see see Amy
and you telling me hey Amy please
schedule a meeting with so-and-so for
some time next week and then Amy just
takes it from there so of course Amy
will start asking nagging you to give
her access to your calendar because that
actually helps us it helps her know make
them form decisions about you know your
available spots your preferences etc and
it's the type of system that the more
information you give it the better the
service it provides so in that sense
it's similar to say like Spotify or
Pandora or something where you want to
tell it your preferences you want to
tell it things about you because then it
just does a better job basically okay so
that's the product intro you can think
of Amy as a seraph conversation model
where we said the entry point was an
email somebody sent an email requesting
say I want to meet with so-and-so and so
the first thing is that Amy needs to
recognize what that email is about needs
to be able to needs to be able to
extract information from that email and
then sort of understand what the meeting
scenario is at that point what
information we have what information we
don't have and once amy understands the
meeting scenario then she takes an
action and the action can be sent an
email to each of the participants with
whatever info then those guys reply and
then the conversation model keeps on
going until serve the meeting is
resolved so we think of it as a change
of state system where the only thing
that we need to determine is what the
scenario of the meeting actually is
right once we know the scenario of the
meeting we don't really care about how
we got there it's because of
deterministic scene
in that sense it's it's basically a pure
Markov process we don't care about the
history of how we got there once we know
where we are we know what action we need
to take and so then the name of the game
is determining what the meeting the
current meeting scenario is so for
example going back to the same process
again we get an email from somebody
requesting a meeting
we checked as the person exists in our
database we have the participant a
proposal time etc etc and all those
pieces of information determine give us
sufficient information to know what the
meeting scenario is and then Amy just
makes a deterministic action based on
that amy follows three directives the
first one is that she is always trying
to minimize ambiguity so she's every
action that she makes has the intent of
minimizing the number of ping-pongs
so converging on the meeting as quickly
as possible the second is as she's
writing things she's communicating with
people in such a way as to facilitate as
much as possible understanding their
answers right so she's trying to make
her life easier and the third one is
that she's trying to make everyone
involved as happy as possible so she's
trying to take everyone's sort of
preferences into account so at the
meeting that she schedules at the end
hasn't just filled an empty slot in
people's calendars but has actually
filled the optimist and you know empty
slot so as you can imagine being a
machine-learning crowd this is a rather
challenging task right it involves
classification information extraction of
various sorts it's the understanding
human language is difficult so in the
time and with the data we have the
system's not yet fully automated so in
this slide I want to kind of describe
that hybrid system which is a temporary
system where and the way that humans
play a role in the system
right now with the caveat that we're
moving very quickly towards a fully
automated system and there's no way that
we can scale or that we can conceive
scaling
with any human involvement in this chain
so the way we can see that is an email
comes in we need to answer maybe a
hundred questions about that email to
determine what meeting scenario we're in
we do try to answer all those questions
through machine learning but some of
those questions for some of those
questions we have higher or lower
confidence levels and so forth those
where the confidence level is not high
enough they get pipeline to someone in
our team who then checks the machine
answer corrects the machine answer if
it's wrong and sort of gives that
feedback to the system increases our
data our annotated data set and so then
the Machine gets better at predicting
that you know that the answer to that
question in the future right so if you
have to resolve maybe 100 different
questions and for a given scenario you
were able to do 70 of them a month from
now you'll be able to do 80 and three
months from now 90 and eventually the
goal is to go to we can answer a whole
hundred of them okay so that's sort of
the product overview now let's dive a
little bit deeper into the actual media
greedy of what we need to do in terms of
machine learning so I'll go through the
same sequence that I've already repeated
a couple of times somebody writes or
than an email this is an actual by the
way this is an actual conversation with
AMI
but it's a conversation I'm not really
revealing any sensitive info because
it's basically our founder trying to
meet with one of the co-founders so
Dennis is asking Amy to coordinate a
meeting with Matt on Monday Amy needs to
recognize that this is the email concern
she needs to recognize that this is a
new meeting request that's a serve
classification task
she needs to then identify information
within the text so people locations
times etc she will notice that in this
case there was no location proposed but
she knows from Dennis's preferences and
calendar that he has a preferred
location which is his office right so
she's able she's has sufficient
information to actually build a template
which he then sends to Matt hey Matt
then he wants to meet with you how about
this time from Monday in his office and
then Matt responds and says 1-2 works we
need to recognize that 1-2 is a temporal
expression that refers to a start time
plus a duration and that the email is
actually accepting something that we
proposed so you can see there's three
basic data science tasks one is
understanding the palin de and the
preferences of the user the other is
classifying emails and the third one is
an information extraction model for text
I'm not actually going to talk about all
the different information extraction
models and classification algorithms
that we have because there's no time for
that but I will describe in some detail
how we handle temporal expressions which
is in itself I find a pretty fascinating
thing so by looking at many many emails
we notice that there's four challenges
to extracting x automatically from text
in emails the first challenge that is
that detection just detecting them
that's particularly difficult in emails
because in emails people have absolute
disregard for grammar right so people
will say like that the example before
1-2 how is that a time right or let's
meet at 230 tomorrow which means anyway
just a side note even doing simple
things like sentence parsing in emails
is hard because people will serve like
artificially break sentences used to
make the emails rectangular which is a
very annoying thing anyway so the
detection problem let's say that you
found Tuesday and the number four you
identified as temporal expressions then
comes a type problem what type of
temporal expressions are this or details
of weeks times intersections offsets
after that Canseco reference problem so
you found two different temporal
expressions in the sentence they're in
different spots of your text but now you
need to somehow ascertain that they
belong to the same time expression
so you need to somehow be able to
associate them and build a more complex
temporal expression from the pieces and
then finally comes the hardest problem
which is yes you have your temporal
expression now you need to resolve it to
an actual time because if the person
said 4:00 p.m. works you need to know
that 4:00 p.m. means year 2015
February 25th at 17 hours UTC and that's
the hard part so before I go into how we
tackle each of these problems let me
just say a few words or about our data
set so pretty early on we undertook a
campaign to go through and annotate by
hand a significant fraction of our data
set width and that's a current
undergoing campaign and so we have
significant data set of emails where we
have fully annotated times people
locations the intent of the email and
not just annotated by hey this word the
simple expression but actually resolving
it resolving the people to what they are
etcetera so that's our corpus but of
course we have many different cases that
we need to handle on some of which are
more frequent than others so even though
you have a significant data set there
are some cases for which we are still
lacking statistics but that's changing
so let me show you an actual plot that
describes our data this is the raw email
traffic through our system so the blue
line is the number of emails that goes
through our system as a function of time
each dot here is the number of emails in
a given day right and so the x-axis is
just nine the y-axis is the number of
years a number of emails but I don't
necessarily want to reveal what the
actual volume that we have but there's
some interesting characteristics about
this already you can see that it's very
rich in structure oh and by the way the
red line corresponds to the number of
emails that have temporal expressions in
that
as you can see we started recording that
sometime in mid-july so you can see for
example that the email traffic has a
strong dependence on the day of week it
actually drops dramatically in the
weekend because people used unscheduled
meetings in weekends there's some
structure that you can see already at
the day of week level so people tend to
schedule more meetings on Mondays and
Fridays because they're planning either
the rest of the week or the next week we
are still at the beta stage so that
means that we have a fixed number of
users and something very beautiful at
this blood is that when we on boarded a
bunch of our beta users at the beginning
you can see that the traffic more or
less stays constant which means that
people that use the system stay and they
keep on using it because they like it
because it works for them and so you can
see the sort of step functions that
correspond to sort of onboarding
campaigns that we've undertaken through
time there's a nice feature here which
is the end of December where you see
this massive drop and that corresponds
to people is going on vacation and
canceling a bunch of meetings and
rescheduling etc so one lesson from this
is that it's a very trivial basic lesson
is that we actually have a dependence so
our data set the properties of our data
set the relative frequencies of the
things inside our data set have a strong
time dependence
whenever there's some event like there's
some were close to some vacation or a
blizzard comes into New York or there's
a hurricane in Miami or whatever we
actually see that our data set changes
so that means that all the machine
learning that we do shouldn't really
depend on those things that are
sensitive to this type of event so we
need to be very careful about the way we
select our features right because it's
that principle that you should apply
your machine learning on things that
have the same probability distributions
as a thing that you trained on and so if
you're probably distribution so any
change then you're paying snagit not
gonna be as good ok so how do we tackle
each of the challenges
associated to time entities so first the
detection challenge and I know this is a
machine-learning crowd so maybe you
might not like what I'm going to say but
a rule-based approach actually worked
very well temporal expressions are
structured enough that a set of rejects
rules actually outperforms most machine
learning that at least all the machine
learning approaches I've seen so we do
take a rejects based approach to
detecting times we complement it with
parts of speech tagging so in some cases
where the thing is ambiguous
like for example worth fall FA ll that
could be a very poor a noun or like a
season of the year but it also also be a
verb so for those ambiguous cases we
just run like conditional random fields
get parts of speech and double check
that this thing's not a verb but most of
the time we just use pure talk and
rejects and actually works quite well so
we've detected the time time entities
now we need to resolve we need to
understand what that those time entities
are what type of a time entity is it a
day of week a time of days it's some
sort of intersect offset etc and after
looking at many many emails we realize
that there's a finite cases it's a
number of cases that we need to learn
how to handle and so yeah we have that
those set of cases and we define a set
of operations that can do various things
with these different types of times
under applying those operations on those
types of times always results in a new
type which is inside the set of types
that we have so it's a closed algebra
and that actually makes makes it good
coding practice in a sense and then the
core efference model so this thing of
having different types of times helps
with the core efference model and now we
actually have very rudimentary
approaches which is we grab a sentence
all the time entities inside that
sentence we compare them through these
operators that we have which tell us
were whether we can merge things or not
and if we can we actually merge them so
an example of that is you have one p.m.
time constraint Tuesday is a day of week
object
operator compare them can you merge them
yes then you create a new object called
weekday time which is Tuesday 1:00 p.m.
and then comes the resolution yes some
extent we have we it's not it's not now
it's not a part of speech tagging but we
add a layer of logical rules on top of
it that's how we handle that everything
or like before this except that or this
type of thing but it gets it gets pretty
complicated and then the last problem
which is resolving the actual temporal
expression into a time this is how we
handle that and I know this look a
little bit abstract and there's no it's
very few wording here but this is
actually the main message of this talk
so if you were gonna take anything from
the stock there will be this slide and
so what we've learned is that the way to
handle a very complex machine learning
task that has a lot of composite
different pieces that some talk to each
others on my independent cetera is to
actually break it down into a set of
very simple binary decisions so let me
give an analogy the analogy of this
would be building a car so imagine in
the 19th century or 18th century I don't
know when cars started to get built you
had maybe three or four engineers that
understood everything about the car and
they built the whole car themselves Ryan
they build the first prototype and maybe
it took them like seven eight months ten
months to build it but now now once you
know what the car is you can actually
break the design and the building of the
car into an assembly line where now you
have a thousand steps that are very
trivial and so maybe step a thousand
seven hundred and five this is some guy
who needs to get this screw and put it
in this place and that guy doesn't
that's the only task he needs to do and
he doesn't really know what else
happened in the train he may not even
know that he's building a car and he
doesn't know how the thing got there and
the simplicity of that task
the fact that you broke it into a set of
sequence of simple tasks is what allows
you to then substitute those humans with
robots there's no way you could build a
robot nowadays I could the robot itself
could build a whole car but you can
build a thousand robots that have
performed very simple tasks and then at
the end of the sequence you get a car
so that's kind of the concept the
concept here let me just dive and show
you an actual sort of an actual example
so you have a time entity that comes in
from the top you have no idea where it
came from or why or what it is and you
just need to answer this very simple
question
it's the email where the time entity is
is it responding to an email where we
propose times yes or no and if the
answer is yes then the next binary
question which is very simple to respond
is does that time match any of the times
that we proposed yes or no you don't
need to know anything else right if it
does then you know that time is
referencing one of the times we proposed
and you've solved the resolution problem
right because now you have full
information about that time so you've
substituted the resolution problem with
it which is very hard with a very easy
problem which is fuzzy matching and say
that yes it matches one of the times
that we proposed if the person is
referencing that time then you see
they're accepting or declining it which
is another simple binary decision all
right so that's breaking it down into
this sort of very simple binary
decisions that require very little
context improved our performance
significantly and it's something that we
can do because we have context because
we live in the closed domain of
scheduling meetings right and so that
restricts the space of possibilities
significantly right so that's when I was
saying before that we don't want to be
too ambitious we want to it's a singular
domain project and that's why we think
we can solve it this is how then it
plays this is where that statement plays
out okay so what's the performance this
is recall and precision
a function of time for some set of weeks
for last year so it's point here is the
recall and precision for a given week
and what I mean by recalling precision
is the full thing not just detecting it
but detecting and I'm resolving it into
the right time stamp so you can see we
have about 85% recall which is good
could still be improved the main
drawback there is how noisy emails are
this is all different ways that people
write mostly sorry things and but once
we do get something and we solve it we
get it right about 97 to 98% of the
times so how does this compare to
research out there so you have to
compare to the strict detection the
strict detection column so there you can
see that the recall for other research
of this type can exceed ours a little
bit the best ones out there are around
89 90 % but that's because they're
training these things on corpuses where
the temporal expressions are actually
well-defined so they're not as noisy or
anywhere else no you see as emails but
now look at the precision the best
positions out there are around 93%
whereas we have 97% and that's basically
thanks to the fact that we can exploit
context so before I wrap up let me say
something I'll email classification so
this time entity is example where we go
through this binary tree that then
picked itself the output of that becomes
features to our classifiers for
classifying emails we take standard
textbook approach we do support vector
machines once one versus all we have a
taxonomy of possible intents for emails
so possible types of emails that we
could have we train a separate SVM for
each we do feature reduction through you
know standard methods like mutual
information we optimize the parameter
space automatically so we surveyed the
whole parameter space for each SVM and
so then an email comes in we hit it with
our 70 or 100 VMs and then it returns
the classes that
email belongs to them the type of
features that we use also standard and
opie features and grants by the way
Ingram is sort of the origin of ami
Ingram's last name then we also use
parts of speech tagging as features
syntax rules based on parts of speech
tagging the output of this decision tree
that I was talking about and context
again context helps us here quite a bit
let me show you one example of
performance of our email classifier this
is how well we're doing in terms of
classifying emails that are new meeting
requests so an email comes in and we
need to determine whether the guy is
requesting a new meeting or he's talking
about something else maybe setting
preferences etc this is the precision of
recall as a function of the confidence
level so the x-axis has nothing to do
with time now it's a confidence level so
you can see that for a confidence level
of 0.9 for example we get about 90% of
the emails that come in there are any
meeting requests with a precision of
around 97% so that's okay but we need to
do significantly better so this is a
very active area of research in the
company so with that a liberal of future
work so there's three very exciting
areas that we're just sort of tapping
into we've already taken the first steps
at them but we want to go much deeper
into them one of them is understanding
people's calendars and calendar
preferences automatically so doing a
bunch of pattern recognition you know
what's your favorite time for meeting
for lunch a business lunch or where type
of thing we wanna enhance our meeting
location model meaning that knowing
certain things about you and your
profile we want to be able to suggest
places for you to meet with people and
also take into account in a better way
than we're doing now travel time between
you know how long is it gonna take you
to get to the next meeting and then we
also wanna extract relationships of your
meeting network so we want to be able to
deduce you know when you meet with this
people you tend to meet in this place
this guy is actually your bus so if he
wants to meet with you at 2:00 that's
gonna take precedence over having coffee
with your friend or something so this
type of thing and with that thank you
very much and I close the talk and open
it for questions and maybe now actually
Nikhil and Angela who are full-time data
scientist in my team I want them to just
join me help me answer some of the
questions their co-author at all these
stuff so so we use stand for NLP parser
and for the time detection stuff we use
Hsu time so it's all within Stanford
basically but it's very the way our so
Stanford NLP gives us some sort of like
seed of information on top of which we
add a bunch of logic layers and that's
actually a module in our system that we
could very easily substitute with any
other like analytical or whatever other
library you would want yeah yeah
so a lot of annotations like usually if
it identifies that most of the times
we have an internal thing to it yeah oh
yeah so he's asking that I was our
annotated data set the result of out you
know crowdsourcing this thing to
Mechanical Turks and the answer is no we
have an internal team and part of the
reason is that we there's an issue when
you go to external mechanical Turks of
releasing sis or revealing sort of
information that could be sensitive yeah
so that so that particular case we
handle by pressing sort of like a snooze
button where we'll pick up you told us
hey leave me alone for a week I don't
know and so we press the snooze button
that then you pick the conversation
would you get picked up again next
Monday unless there's some pressing
decision that needs to happen because
the meeting will happen before and we
need to resolve it before that certainly
certainly yeah yeah we understand that
that type of situation yeah
can you elaborate on that lumen yeah
yeah yeah oh I see what you mean so
that's that's a very interesting and at
the same time not too far fetched
functionality that Amy could take on and
that we thought about so weird yeah so
answer will be yes in the near future
yes yes we're yeah we're shooting for
that and for that we need to learn the
relationships between the people are
having a meeting
so the rule-based system that we have is
applied to a very limited to a very
specific problem which is detecting
temporal expressions and temporal
expressions are structured enough that
having a rule-based system actually does
quite well
obviously it's very hard for me to
conceive that that couldn't be
outperformed by machine learning so I
strongly suspect that we can outperform
that with machine learning yeah you mean
like what languages we use etcetera so
back-end Scala so we're all Scala freaks
we do some Python for like exploration
stuff database MongoDB 30 WS
sorry repeat the question
I think the question is if the email has
a very short text like it's just two or
three words how do you detect what it
means so yeah so one of this one of the
strong features for us is the entire
email thread like for example if it's
the first email that comes in it's very
unlikely that it's going to be an except
I'm intention email and like the
likelihood of it being a new meeting is
much higher so such context and the
previous emails on the thread also help
so it's not just that one single
sentence that we are looking at but the
entire history in the conversation yeah
yeah so we use a bunch of contacts based
in features so for example what that
email is responding to right so you
could think of this as sort of like
bootstrapping method where if I know
what the email if I have full
information or the the preceding email
that actually informs quite a bit and
restricts the space of possibilities of
the current email yes it's a pure bits
decision tree that's what it is but it's
just that I think it's it's that it's
the effort to make each node in the
decision tree a binary a purely binary
decision that is very very context
independent and it's just as simple as
it possibly can be right so we rather
answer 200 very simple questions than 10
very complex questions not they're all
machine learning based they're all
machine learning all of them well some
of them are not because they're purely
mechanical you can deduce them
deterministically from context
yeah indeed
yeah so the first question was emails
our email bodies are accompanied with a
lot of noisy stuff like signatures
disclaimers etc so a lot of quite a bit
of work goes into actually detecting and
parsing the email out into these
different pieces for signature stripping
which is a classic problem we use um
actually SVM's to do that so we have
several handles to determine what the
signature you know if this part of the
email is a signature or not and if it is
them we have a whole model to handle
that but we don't discard it because
actually signatures are quite
information rich so he tell us a lot of
personal information or the person who's
using the system like his name his
office his telephone etc so it's not
like we discarded because this is very
useful information in the context of a
meeting so that's the first question the
second question is how we make sure that
we can handle say 1 million meetings
going through our system that's a purely
engineering question right so we have
qyz we just spin up more instances in
AWS right so you paralyze the process
that's
but the email is the the SVM is trained
offline and then once you have the
trainer's VM then you just have the
little you know about your hyperplane or
and you just make decision making that
the prediction takes like a millisecond
can you I think I understand more that's
why you sent back you elaborate a little
bit oh okay so you have to do you wanna
you're thinking of two separate
identities for Amy in a sense I mean you
can trick a me into thinking that you're
two different people right if that's
what you mean we haven't really
developed a model for that but it's it's
an interesting idea right so for us
that's at the absolutely worst case
scenario right where we just have no
idea and we're confused and we give up
and so then we need to request for
clarification which happens sometimes
because people are can be very ambiguous
with and as also people fool around with
Amy quite a bit so there is that case
where we either pipeline it to customer
support or send back a request
clarification type of email but we try
to avoid that so our whole focus is to
minimize that that type of the type of
case
so oh in that sense so there's so
there's two answers to York so your
question and I think I know what you
mean but the first one is we retain
information on the user's yes for the
sake of making the service better for
them so if you connect that you're
telling their once we're going to keep
you asking for your calendar but that's
not what you mean I understand yeah
slang or language I think it's a
beautiful idea to try to customize Amy
to its individual user that Amy so sort
of trained Amy to understand a specific
user as well as possible one and even
try to talk to that user in his own
language I think that's a I think that's
a beautiful idea but no we're not doing
that right now
thank you thank you for asking that so
happy that you asked that so I think one
of the sweet spots of Amy is yeah so the
answer is yes we can customize Amy for a
specific corporation that has 20,000
employees and imagine all of them when
they onboard the company they get their
Amy account so now typically when you
schedule a meeting within our company
it's like hey can you guys meet on this
day and there's a whole ping-pong and
you get to know when the meetings gonna
happen with those two people maybe a day
or two afterwards
whereas if everybody had Amy and I was
to request a meeting with you three I
would send out the meeting proposal and
sort of magically and immediately we
will all get a meeting invitation like
seconds afterwards which somehow
maximizes all of our preferences right
so that's really a sweet sweet spot of
Amy I think
yeah we get that all the time
OOP time since our absolute nightmare
that we can handle but it has been
through the massive amounts of pain but
yes we've learned how to handle time
zones we do have a way of handling
illogical cases so things that don't
make sense I don't know if you wanted to
lab so somebody says let's meet on the
31st of February we are capable of
identifying that as a analogical time
and then we have two solutions either we
try to guess what he actually meant and
act on that and allow that person to
correct us down the line if we're wrong
or to go back to a person and say and
try to just clarify is hey we noticed
that you proposed this but it's what you
actually meant this yeah
so developing that architecture
developing understanding what that logic
tree is is the result of analyzing the
data for a long time and understanding
all the possible cases that we all the
possible scenarios that we have in
meetings so that's kind of equivalent of
we now have the card prototype so we
know all the different pieces and what
talks to each other and what we can
decouple right so that's what goes into
the design of that logic tree and so
each step of the logic tree kind of
reduces the the space of possibilities
that that thing can be and so it's kind
of narrowing down and almost
deterministically telling you where you
are yeah
so that's also a good question that is a
function of the number of people in the
meeting as well so if we're scheduling a
meeting with two or three people then a
me starts talking individually to each
of them so you talk individually you
negotiate with Amy but now this guy
rejected a time and so that information
that needs to travel horizontally and
affects the conversation with somebody
else right so it's one to one of course
that becomes sort of intractable if you
go to meetings with more than five or
six people where now you we adopt a
different strategy where we maybe I'm
sure we're developing a model for that
still but where we maybe talk to several
people at the same time and of course we
only talk to those people who are not
using Amy because those are using Amy
then it's Amy talking to Amy internally
and we don't need to bother them Frank
so Amy access sort of like the interface
between all the different conversations
different participants yeah so Amy is
waiting for the response of everybody
right and so if that guy's responded
already then we we know the information
for that person and we need to see
whether that the other person agrees
with that or where that matches the
other person if not or not right so if
the other person now rejects that time
that Amy needs to go back to this guy
and say hey that time actually won't
work what about this other time
sometimes we face the case where the
second guy just doesn't reply and the
first time actually becomes invalid so
that also triggers a response from Amy
and she contacts the first person again
and but there's a time pressure right
which is the meeting time that the host
won it and so as things get closer to a
meeting time we become more aggressive
with the people